nathan the baldy three and two coming in
he really has pitched exceptionally well
against baltimore two of his three wins
have come against them 100 miles an hour
to strike down mullins one gone dj
stewart at 219.
and there's another one he's two for two
on strikeouts two away in the first
inning so they do get a man on base
before nunez gets up who has incredible
numbers against the ball one two to
nunes and a swing and a miss to put him
away
so he strikes out three in the opening
frame dean kramer's numbers this season
this will be his fourth start it's
already picked up his first major league
win very impressive one six nine earned
run average comes jackie bradley first
and third two down
and that one rope into right field for a
base hit that'll chase in verdugo
and move xander bogarts around to third
base jackie bradley as hot as a
firecracker these days he puts the red
sox in the lead so red sox making this
impressive youngster work in the first
thing here's pawecki and the 01 pitch
little pounding ball that's going to
squeak on through for a base hit another
run is in
bogart's touching home plate
jackie bradley into third the red sox
keep the merry-go-round going it's
two-nothing jd martinez flying to center
first trip he's over one
center field well struck mullins is back
we'll play it off the padded wall
[Applause]
here's the play at the plate the throw
won't get him and the red sox have it on
a run
jd martinez with an rbi double to make
it three to nothing yeah that's more
like a jd fastball line drive off the
center field fence i didn't think i had
enough to get out of here that would
have been impressive bandit third
poleecki the batter
tagged into right field a diving effort
it's going to get on by he's run run run
a run is in
flowecki heading into third
and he will pull up there
he's got himself a triple to drive in
another run to make it four to nothing
see how long the young right-hander
kramer lasts in this one he's down four
to nothing
roughed up in the first and again here
in the third inning
turns on that one and rips that one
toward the wall it'll land right at the
base of the green monster
here comes the run trying to score and
dulbeck is in standing up to make it
five to nothing the rbi to chavis and
here comes brandon hyde this could be it
he's walked the nine hitter arroyo two
times
brandon with the slow walk
and there's the call to the bullpen so
the night's over
for dean kramer not a good one
bases all loaded up
there's a line shot
that's all the way to the wall
one run is in
two runs are in
three runs are in as berdugo scores all
the way down to second base cleaning
them off
rafael devers and the red sox are on top
eight to nothing forget about it it was
no fastball up high it was no curveball
down it was a split that was down about
knee high he just breaks it those have
four hits two of them by mount castle
and here's renato nunez who struck out
swinging
one hopper flipped into second bow
guards with plenty of time turns two so
double play two goals a couple of men on
with one away against vivaldi number
nine hitter
two-two and hammered on the infield
maybe a double play four six three and
there it is bruce zimmerman now in the
ball game of course got his first major
league start out of the way
verdugo down on strikes technically it's
two strikeouts in the inning for
zimmerman champs cisco steps in with
stuart at second nunez at first oh two
swinging a miss 98 miles an hour
to strike him out
as his eighth of the ball game eight to
nothing boston
might kick him to make an appearance
here out of the bullpen following
nate of aldi's really fine outing he'll
face austin hayes
2-2 that's hit well
way back and it is upstairs
into the monster seats austin hayes
home run number three for him
slider kind of spinning up there and he
took care of business
so two down they're on at first and
third here for christian arroyo
that'll skip away here comes jackie
bradley jr he will slide in safely
as it got away from cisco to catch her
that'll make it nine to one that's got a
good jump
buster got a good job got to go right
away or forget about it suddenly the
base is loaded here for the orioles
frank's trying to put him away
and drills it in there for strike three
caught him looking
two down that'll send up ruiz who on the
night is all for three
bounty ball to first snatch there by
dalbeck there's one more out to get
here's stewart
cut on and miss for strike three an
appropriate way to end that 13 red sox
strikeouts tonight and the sox win this
one going away 9-1